welcome to scitrek the tv movie fantasy
and sci-fi channel that's just for you
so the final season of lucifer is upon
us and the advert has finally dropped
i don't think a lot of smoke in here
oh dear what will become of me what's
your name
lucifer
exactly i've got to say i'm really
excited to see where they're going to go
this final series because let's be
honest in the five seasons running up to
this they've never disappointed
your return to the underworld has been
requested
oh
so i'd love to talk a little bit about
this tv show and why i love it so much
and what i'm hoping to see in the final
series because this is one of those few
tv shows that i really really love
that i've even convinced the wife to
watch
this tv show hit amazon prime a few
years ago and i have to say initially i
thought
dear god what a stupid concept
detective i believe you left these after
our sleepover last night what's the hole
at the back for
not mine those are not mine
well come on there girl fair enough
dear me
someone woke up on the wrong side of a
38.
it's satan
fighting crime oh come on
who thought that would work
but just like brilliant tv shows like
firefly who thought a western in space
would work well most people didn't
that's why it got canned quite quickly
but oh my god did it it was one of the
best sci-fi shows ever made
lucifer is along the similar sort of
vein to that completely out of left
field completely not normal and
completely brilliant
don't mind if i did
and they cast the series beautifully tom
ellis as lucifer couldn't have been any
better
he's a british actor that we know from
little sitcoms and things over the years
and when he went over to america
nobody really expected to see him again
you know little fish big pond well he
got this part and he
camped it up beautifully
up down on the ground well i'd really
rather not i've just got into some clean
clothes partner name and badge number oh
for goodness sake detective decker i'm
afraid i don't know a badge number
but i'd say with certainty she's a 34 b
if that helps
but then there are other characters like
db woodside who we know from tv shows
like 24
and buffy the vampire slayer things like
that he came into this show and just
called lucifer lucy from
day one
the mana deal
okay
hello
hey lucy
just again
genius a little bit of writing genius
cute play between the characters and it
just worked from day one
and the character of satan in this
series as well is
again genius completely based on the
biblical text now not the black and
white good versus evil character of
satan that you know the roman catholic
church ran down our throat but the
actual reality of the biblical text that
actually lucifer isn't really a bad guy
he was sent down to hell to punish the
wicked this was his job his fight
against god was not really about
good versus evil it was about him
thinking he could do a better job than
the almighty
and actually in this series we're going
to find out whether he's right or not
she likes you
of course she does what's not to like
the series works and the series was
genius because from day one they filmed
it with a really dark humor and they
taught us the lesson that actually life
isn't black and white it isn't good
versus evil life has its grace
and we're all here just trying to figure
out
what our place is in this wonderful
crazy thing we call life
so please here's the advert enjoy and
look forward to the series on netflix
september 10th
let's just start with what you were
doing before the event this evening i
was driving a motorcycle cop you were
bribing a police officer indeed not for
the first time and up until recently you
consulted for the lapd
and you also claim that you're the devil
was the devil god now well nearly and
how old would you say you are again one
time works very differently in hell so
he's just sensitive about his age i mean
even i don't know the real number
it's time for you to assume your place
on father's throne what's the rush
becoming god is a big job maybe he
doesn't want to go in half cup i should
definitely be full cocked
i need your help i thought i wasn't your
therapist anymore and look at what's
happened
the world has no god clearly i belong on
this couch
lucifer
what is that
is my friend
excuse me
something i can help you with wanna help
me destroy lucifer morningstar
the laws of nature are breaking down
and the apocalypse is nice
there's only one thing we can do
vacation in colombia beautiful beaches
mountains of illicit drugs
[Music]
relax dude he was like that when i found
him
[Music]
never bring a knife to a devil fight
[Music]
i'm ready i'm sorry because i make quite
the entrance
we still have one mystery left to solve
the murder of lucifer morningstar
[Music]
i certainly did not see this coming
i couldn't look you in the eye
you're just
like an angel
your skin
makes me cry
you flowed like a father
in a beautiful world
oh i wish i was
special
you're so
very special
but i'm
a creep
[Music]
i'm a weedle
what the hell am i doing
here
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Music]